well in this country LeBron James pushes
left-wing politics the NBA touts itself
as a socially conscious sports league
but neither one dares criticize their
masters in China and they don't want
anyone else doing it either because they
don't want to lose money Dennis Rodman
won five NBA championships with the
Chicago Bulls the Detroit Pistons but
after leaving the NBA s at something of
a second career as an informer informal
diplomat he's made multiple trips in
North Korea where he's befriended the
country's dictator we just spoke with
Rodman here's how it went
so when you see LeBron James it's not
just LeBron James but NBA players and
coaches unwilling to tell the truth
about the Chinese dictatorship what's
your response to that well I just look
at it for some I think that uh mb is a
great great sport there's a court around
the world yeah I think MBA players have
an obligation to do one thing is to face
force yeah I think I think when you put
politics with sport it doesn't it
doesn't mix right though I think that
the fact that you know when you when you
put politics in sports it seems to have
a different twist on the game of the of
the sports world and basketball is a
very very universal sport in a species
violence around the world I think the
players the players in in the NBA had no
informants about what's going on in
China or in Hong Kong so I think that
they were there was I think there was
misinformed or it wasn't it wasn't known
to them what was written was taking
place right now
but they also have Google and some of
these guys respond LeBron James is smart
no one no one thinks he's dumb LeBron
James has spent you know years
critiquing American politics he's got no
problem attacking the government here
but anyone who attacks the government
there should be punished to me he said
that that seems like a double standard
well I just think that the culture in
Hong Kong and in China a very
great great country of badass and they
they feed up the American people and
American Way
and they the fact that a lot of people
at the Forster culture in China in Hong
Kong it's very difficult to try to
change that culture overnight because
they have a certain way of living and
for some we're thinking I think the fact
that if DMV a place any players any
sport that has anything to do is force
if they understand the culture of the
Asian community in an age of countries I
think they should understand the fact
that they are very loyal
they're very loyal people if they say
yes they mean yes if they see they hear
something that's very out of contest
they take it in the wrong and they taken
in a different direction so wait a
minute hold on you know no but what if
you had a country that was taking people
Muslims in this case and putting them in
concentration camps or a country that
was executing anyone who disagreed with
the government and then selling their
organs would it be okay if you're an
American to say I know it's a different
culture but you know that's kind of
disgusting
well it is disgusting I think the fact
that you know it's up to the people in
Washington the part of the politicians I
think I guess this voice is force I
think that people are explains forces
force basketball that's not that
concerned I think you can voice your
opinion in America but once you start
going across to over the Asia China the
Singapore Beijing and those countries
over there there's a difference a
different way of living over there
you've got to be really careful what you
say I know that for the Chinese but here
in America were protected by this
umbrella called the Constitution the
Bill of Rights and we can say whatever
we want so LeBron James goes into a
meeting of dean of teammates and team
owners and says anybody who criticizes
China ought to be punished in the United
States what do you think of that well I
think it's difficult I said politicians
who understand the fact that you know
don't involve people like us as far as
athletes involved in politics I think
LeBron James was the first important
individual I think it's very he's very
caring about the people around the world
and especially his charity he doesn't
want to
but I think that you just got to
understand it we don't know too much
about politics we don't want I don't
want to know too much about politician
the Brawn James continued to comment on
American politics well you know one of
the great things about living in America
we got the freedom of speech and then
the Brawn says you have to be punished
for that but I'm standing with the
dealer's though we have no right as
American people to sit to criticize
China or any country in the world in
this sense because you know why China is
wonderful country but they really praise
American people they love sports they
love American people Hong Kong love
American people China
I mean Singapore Beijing Shanghai every
Asian country they love American people
especially sports I think if people in
sports athletes understand that because
they're very lured to people it's for
the American people so I think that the
broad Jason understand you know what
keep let the politics be politics and
let the basketball players be basketball
players well I hope he would he would
live by that standard here too
I'm not sure I understood a lot of that
but I really appreciate it
it's great to see you thanks a lot for
coming up Dennis Rodman thank you